now in Gabon the Junta leaders are
releasing a number of political
prisoners in the capital libreville
self-declared a transitional president
brisoliji in grema granted them amnesty
during his inauguration on Monday let's
bring in our correspondent Nicholas hack
he's across this for us from the
Senegalese Capital Dhaka Nick General
and guemma really feels like he's
underlining how different things are
after ending The Bongo Dynasty
that's right now says that he seems to
be putting word to action by freeing all
these political prisoners it'll be three
of them the former mayor of libreville a
high official from The Bongo regime and
this unionist this very famous unionist
in Gabon Joe who came out from prison
after spending two years in detention
for being critical of Ali Bongo saying
this is a new beginning for the country
and while there are people being
released from prison there are those
that are being arrested hundreds of them
Close Associates or Allies to Ali Bongo
currently under detention and we're
being told being interrogated is the
Minister of oil and gas
who appeared for many Japanese to be
above the law a man that's in charge of
a big portfolio remember Gabon has
exported six billion dollars of oil last
year where did that money go will be the
question put to him meanwhile there is
president Twitter from the Central
African Republic who's in the country
trying to mediate an end to this coup
saying that there needs to be a return
to constitutional order and that Ali
Bongo needs to be freed
Nick I see that General griem has also
met with the opposition leader there any
talk of when we should expect elections
well we don't even know what the charter
of transition is so there's no
indication of the dates of a new
election or what his plan moving forward
is however we can see we can see that
he's trying to dismantle the whole Bongo
system The Bongo Dynasty that has been
in power for the last 55 years and that
will take time of course and and it's
interesting to know that President
whilst he's still in the country right
now his main objective is not
necessarily to bring back Ali Bongo back
to power but to find a safe way out for
him and his family to be released
there's also Silvia Bongo and his son
nurudeen who's a key player in the
government now they've been accused of
high treason we've been told that Ali
Bongo is being kept in his presidential
Palace he doesn't have access to his
phone he doesn't have access to his
doctor and and there's real concern
about his health so that's the main
objective of president wadera but Sema
which is the regional body has come out
and has condemned the coup there is real
fear from neighboring countries such as
Cameroon where polby has been present
since 1982 or uh or president obiang in
Equatorial Guinea that this contagion of
coup could spread but the template of
coups that we've seen in former French
colonies in the Sahel is very different
to the one that we're seeing in Gabon
we're seeing that oligi and guema is
still and remains a close Ally to France
the former colonial power that has
numerous military bases on the ground in
liberville necklace hack across that for
us from Dakar thank you very much Nick